This is your first win in any Grand Slam Main Draw on the 15th attempt.
I want to say thank you to my coach, my parents.
Thank you everybody who came to support me.
Thank you.
I just try to focus.
I don't want to think about winning or losing...
...because always, you think, "Okay, last point."
"If you win this point, you win the match."
Sometimes you lose the whole match.
So, I don't want to lose the focus.
And I want to concentrate on the last point.
I just want to show the best of Zhang Shuai in this match.
Before the match I think this is, in my life, maybe the last match.
I try to do my best in the match.
I want to try my best.
I want to show the best of Zhang Shuai.
I think I did a great job today.